injured during a stampede at the
National Stadium these people were
brought to a hospital in Madagascar's
capital and nanarivo a survivor of the
crush says a group of fans tried to push
in
um
the policemen told them to go away but
the delinquents pushed us through the
portal and I fell down people stepped on
my head and I totally blacked out
some people were killed and dozens
injured
my son and his friend went to the games
together he is in coma and his face is
swollen but he is just showing some
movement we didn't know that he was here
we came here at six in the evening
yesterday
at least 15 people were killed in a
similar incident at the same stadium in
2019 the venue managers are facing
scrutiny over the handling of crowds and
security the government says it will
support victims of the Stampede
most of the injured will be going back
home the government and the ministry of
Public Health will take care of their
bills none of them will pay for their
treatment
the Indian Ocean Island games are held
every four years between nations
including Mauritius the Seychelles and
the kimuras but this 11th Edition has
opened with tragedy Barbara angopa Al
Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera